we began of course in Southern
California which faces an unprecedented
fire threat is major wildfires burn
across a region more than 300,000 people
are under evacuation orders this morning
powerful Santa Ana winds gusting up to
80 miles an hour they're making these
fires extremely dangerous and very
unpredictable unprecedented his right
Gale four large fires are burning north
and west of Los Angeles the threat level
index is red in Ventura and Los Angeles
counties it was raised to purple in some
places that is a level that has never
been used before CBS Evening News anchor
Jeff Glor is in shadow Hills where the
Creek fire destroyed dozens of homes
Jeff good morning Nora good morning to
you this property we're standing on what
was a home is one of around 200
structures that have been destroyed in
the California wildfires this week so
far you can see basically just a chimney
is left behind us here these four fires
alone have burned territory now bigger
than the city of Atlanta and the strong
worry is that is about to get worse
overnight the Thomas fire in Ventura
County closed in on the town of Ojai
burning around highway 33
I was expecting you know this year to
see snow on that mountain and now the
things on fire wind subsided Wednesday
but have picked up again fanning flames
across Southern California devastated
and every friend we talked to us in the
same boat where the flames are now out
often nothing is left cat Merrick and
Chris Corson's return to their home in
the Ventura hillside it is now in ashes
the photos and the mementos in the you
know the family heirlooms they just
they're gone and they're not coming back
as the Thomas fire inched toward Santa
Barbara County this man pulled over the
side of highway 1 and rushed to rescue
an animal the 405 was closed for hours
near the famous Getty Museum Wednesday
as the Skirball fire crossed the freeway
I go over here whole mountains on fire
in bel-air same fire ripped through
multi-million dollar homes while
firefighters on the ground worked away
here in Los Angeles County more than
1500 people are battling the Creek fire
250,000 people have been evacuated and
more than 12,000 acres burned I'm numb I
don't know
Judi Hoffman Sanders lives in shadow
Hills where the fire has already
destroyed her house the house was just
wonderful
I don't know what's going to happen I
have to sit down and Judi Hoffman
Sanders actually lived right on this
property to give you a little
perspective on what's happened here this
is what the house looked like before the
Creek fire and you see exactly what it
looks like right now about 50 miles
northwest of Los Angeles that Thomas
fire in Ventura County forced new
evacuations overnight it is the largest
of the four fires and it's only 5%
contained at this point and David Begg
know is on the fire lines in Ojai
California David good morning to you
Jeff where we are right now winds are
actually carrying the fire toward Ojai
you've got flames that are burning on
the northwestern side of town the
northern and parts of the eastern side
the area of LA conchita is under a
mandatory evacuation the winds are
starting to pick up the smoke is pretty
unreal in this area in fact just
recently we saw a wall of flames that
had to have been 300 feet or higher
you know the LA Fire index LA fire burn
index is the highest it's ever been
projected an extreme reading is 162 you
know what it is today
296 Jeff David thank you very much